- [Voiceover] "Which of
the following is equivalent
"to the complex number shown above?"
And then we got this big, hairy mess here.
Where we wanna take
the rational expression
one plus i over one minus i,
and then add that to one over one plus i.
Well when you had two fractions like this
what you might wanna do is
find a common denominator.
And the easiest way to
find a common denominator
is to take the product
of both of these things.
So let me just rewrite everything.
So we wanna take one plus i
over one minus i,
and then add that, and
let me switch some colors
so we can keep track of things.
And then add that to one plus...
Or one over one plus i.
And actually, let me give
myself some space here.
So, plus...
Plus one over
one plus i.
Well we're able to add
two fractions if we have
the same denominator.
And we can have the same
denominator if we multiply
both the numerator and
the denominator here
by this denominator by one plus i,
and if we multiply both
the numerator and the
denominator here by this denominator,
and this is the way
that you've always added
fractions with unlike denominators,
we're just finding a
least common multiple,
and that least common multiple the easiest
one is just multiplying the denominators.
So let's do that, so let's
multiply the numerator
and denominator here.
Put the parenthesis time one plus i.
And let's
multiply the denominator here times
one plus i.
So notice one plus i over
one plus i that's just
going to be one,
so we aren't changing its
value, we're just going to
find another way of expressing it.
And this one over here
we wanna multiply the
numerator and the denominator...
And the denominator
by this denominator,
by one minus i.
One minus i, so we're
gonna multiply times...
We're gonna take this and
multiply one minus i...
Multiply by one minus i over one minus i,
and once again, this thing
right over here is just one
so we're not changing its
value, we're just finding a good
way to rewrite it so
that we're going to have
the same denominator.
Notice, both of these denominators are
now going to be the same
thing, they're gonna be
one plus i times one minus i.
Let's figure out what this is.
So this first one
right over here.
So the numerator...
So let's see, we're
gonna have one times one.
Let me do this in different
colors, this way we can
keep track of everything.
So we have this numerator right over here.
One times one is one.
One times i is i.
I times one is i.
And then i times i is
negative one.
Is negative one.
And then this denominator over here
is going to be, so we're
gonna have divided by
one times one, and you
could say that this is
a difference of squares right over here.
Let me just multiply it
out, we'll see that it's a
difference of squares.
So one times one is one.
One times plus i is plus i.
Negative i times one is minus i.
And then negative i times positive i.
Well, i times i would be negative one,
but then we have this
negative so it's just
going to be plus one.
And so, what does this simplify to?
Let's see, you're gonna have
one minus one.
So those cancel out.
And then you're gonna have this i minus i,
that's just gonna be zero.
So this simplifies in the numerator,
you have two times i.
And then in the denominator...
In the denominator you have one plus one
is equal to two.
And I could simplify
this, but my goal isn't to
simplify this, my goal
is to have the same...
Is to have like denominators,
so I'm just gonna leave
this like this, just like that right now.
And now let's move on to this one.
Let's move on to this
one, so the numerator...
The numerator here is
pretty straight forward,
one times one minus i,
that's just gonna be one
minus i.
And then the denominator
here, one plus i times
one minus i, we just figure that out.
That simplifies to two.
So that simplifies to two.
So this has now become
two i over two, plus
one minus i
over two.
Well what's that going to mean?
Well...
Our denominator's going to be two.
You could say that we have two i halves
plus one minus i half, so how many halves
is that going to be?
Well, we wanna add...
This has no real part, so you wanna add
the imaginary parts.
So we're gonna have the one.
This one.
And then we could add...
Take two i and then subtract i from that,
two i minus i is going to be i.
So it's going to be
one plus i over two.
And the don't have exactly that,
but if we then if we just...
Instead of writing it like
this, if we viewed this as...
If we viewed this as
one half times one plus i,
which this is the same thing,
or if we viewed this as
one half, if we distribute the one half.
One half plus
one half i, or plus...
Let me just write it.
One half plus one half i.
And when we write it that way...
When we write it that
way, we see this choice
is exactly that.
And we are done.